saved by the bell
how old were you when you started that i
was 15 when i started i said i did it
from 15 to 20. were you this
exceptionally good-looking kid like did
your mom push you and you say listen
you're so [ __ ] good-looking we're
taking you down to save by the bell no
my parents are from mexico i'm first
generation here i grew up in chula vista
which is the border town right there
right to tijuana right not the most
upscale neighborhood so yeah so my old
man worked for the city my mom for the
phone company and um she just kept me
busy in as many activities as possible
to keep me out of trouble getting sports
this kind of thing explore everything
that's how you get that physique right
you got to start young with that [ __ ] i
yeah i grew up wrestling my uncles
wrestled so i grew up wrestling i should
have wrestled
if i had wrestled i mean you know what
it is i i lived like a veal i didn't do
anything yeah you stayed in a box i sat
in my room i was afraid i didn't have a
choice like every day i had an activity
so i just thought that's what every kid
did were you a natural athlete um yeah
it came it came uh it came kind of you
know kind of easy well i don't i
wouldn't know
you were the complete opposite of me
what what sports were you good at
mainly the combat sports like wrestling
yeah and boxing yeah me too
those are the only ones i could play
with the individual sports because the
team sports you always had to be there
and always had different activities so
it wasn't fair to the rest of you i hope
you do show to con karate the best
karate there is of course yes yeah when
i was when i was little uh i kind of
explored with everything but then i
focused on until this day i still box no
kidding aren't you afraid of [ __ ] up
your face well there were a certain
headgear you know that you could it it
protects the grill you can still get
knocked out but it's it's a certain
little bar can you handle these do guys
challenge you because you're so handsome
and their girlfriends freak out over you
did you used to get into like fights in
a bar even when you got famous i would
imagine that this was a skill that came
in handy yeah it did come in handy but
then i got sued three times really
fights yeah so i i stopped i'm about to
it was all about turning the other cheek
all three times really a guy coming up
to you and going hey man you know too
you know like starting with you yeah the
last one i remember i was in daytona
beach florida and it was bike week
and it was like that's a rough time yeah
right and i remember the bartender a
female bartender she was like last call
but she still served me a drink yeah
they said why are you serving hollywood
to drink just and i said hey man here
you go you know you're cool yeah have a
good time and then he's i don't need
your [ __ ] and they started just like hey
dude i don't want any problems this and
that
you know he shoved me came back he was a
bigger guy you know i always have a
strike first and boom boom and
uh he ended up busting his eyelid and
and next thing i know i got a little
knock on my hotel room was the cop and i
said it was self-defense but you have to
let them technically hit you first i
learned all about the law in the state
of florida but everyone knows in a bar
fight
you know when you're about to get
whacked you can't let the guy whack you
first because you'll be most bad fights
you'll go down and come back you're good
guys a lot bigger than me yeah so when
you hit this guy
you knock him out with the first punch
he he dropped he wasn't out but he was
where did you hit him yeah so i hit him
in the bar right and then he kind of
fell to the bar i said oh [ __ ] so then i
was staying at the hotel i remember
right next door so i was like i was with
my one buddy he had a because everybody
else went went away already so i said
let's get out of here so we went out of
here we left and then they followed us
and i'm hitting the hotel button i'm
trying to get up to i don't want any
more trouble and then he comes and
already his eye was swollen it was
already getting kind of you know he had
like a mouse yeah and he said you sucker
punched me he's like a sucker punched
you so and then i go hey man i don't and
he started circling me again so the
elevator doors wouldn't open so that i
had to hit him again
and he took him down yeah he dropped
again
he kind of slides up to the side
is it great being good looking at a real
man i've never dropped anyway i've been
dropped many times